aujourd'hui on prend de nouvelles
simplement on veut savoir la population
ou est-ce que vous en ai femmes/hommes
personnes âgées étudiants salariés ou
pas quoi qu'il en soit où vous en êtes
quels sont vos problèmes quels sont vos
problématiques vous avez besoin de quoi
pour passer le confinement nous ce qu'on
va organiser et ce qu'on organise tout
simplement
c'est une forme de téléthon on met en
réseau des personnes des compétences des
connaissances pour apporter des
solutions techniques à chacun de vos
problèmes
à chacun de vos besoins à partir de
lundi vous pourrez remplir sur le lien
en dessous un petit questionnaire vous
faites votre retour vous nous dites
votre ressenti sur la situation de quoi
vous avez besoin qu'on parle de mobilité
l'alimentation de petites choses de
divertissement fait nouveau retour et on
serra en essaiera au mieux de remplir
cette tâche il a accompagné la
population dans cette période difficile